Barbie's taking over huh I mean I dyed
my hair blonde you know what I'm saying
like you think you're not going to lean
in and then you find yourself dying your
hair blonde or in Ryan's case shaving
his legs you're wearing neon
rollerblades and then you're wearing
lightning bolt headbands and you're
always you have to lean in casually
wearing fake minks
it's your end when you're in you're you
go hard there's something to be said
about Barbie giving us permission to
express ourselves like this though right
how's the film Bargo to see your vision
experience this wave I am just so
excited we're at the point of sharing it
with the world because there's always
that thing when you make a movie and you
love it and you care about it so much
and you hope that people are going to
like it and even see it you know like
even if they don't like it I just hope
they see it and get to form an opinion
but I feel like so many people are gonna
see this movie that it's it's really
exciting and it really is Greta's Vision
I mean the vision for Bobby obviously
started 64 years ago but Greta bringing
it into the world today in the way that
only Greta go we can is what makes this
movie worth making right now I could not
stop smiling watching this I know Margo
you said you had a conditional request
for Greta that was to have a slide that
went from Barbie's bedroom to the pool
so yeah Ryan do you have any requests
for Ken you know just like
accommodations really like a place to
stay a at night we're still not sure
what happens to the Ken's when the
Barbies go home
we think they huddle on the beach for
warmth yeah
over the campfire right no fire no fire
over there no no elements that's true
flickering plastic we'll take that was
there a feature of your guys's
characters as Barbie and Ken that you
kind of miss or maybe don't miss because
you did go like Platinum I was gonna say
I miss the big Bobby hair right that
could change with an outfit you know if
she wears her Beach outfit her hair
might be down to here and then in the
next scene her hair's up to here because
she's changed outfits and her hair
magically changes too
so cool
any part of can that you miss I miss the
headbands you do yeah okay you rocked
the headband you really did did you take
any of those home oh yeah yeah I love it
I love it um how excited are your
daughters for this movie I think they're
pretty exciting excited yeah yeah do
they play with Barbies did you join in
on the fun I do I'm not sure that I'm
good at it I'm not sure how to be good
at it but I think it's also like a can
I'm not sure exactly what my place is in
the in the game you know it's just to be
there as long as I'm just you know
appreciated
right thank you for saying that thank
you Mark wow
thank you all right and the soundtrack
to This film is so epic but I gotta know
Ryan so Matchbox 20 did you have a say
in what the Kent were going to seeing
over the campfire no that was all that
was like it was definitely that song and
Greta was um
I love that so adamant it's perfect love
that song I never really heard that song
I've heard that well I mean I heard the
song but I didn't hear the song Oh I
hadn't heard the lyrics right you had no
I had never I I sung that as a kid
without realizing what the words were
yes but I think that's like a lot of
what Greta has and you have done with
this film is that they're making you
kind of look at this these things that
you grew up with I want to push you down
okay that's interesting
it really is though isn't it and I'm not
gonna lie like
having this like we make a joke about
like you know cemu's like do you want me
to play this song while I stare into
your eyes uncomfortably for four and a
half minutes and she's like sure and
it's yeah like when you say like you
want to come inside I'll play guitar at
you not to you at you and as a girl
you're kind of like oh
so the thing that guys do but also I'm
so the girl that that works on because I
was just sitting there the whole time
like this is great on that note the men
had an epic musical number two I mean
Margo what's your reaction when you saw
Ken's musical number I I all of us
Barbies were pretty pissed that we we
suddenly wanted to redo our Barbie dance
because we were like oh no they brought
it but the bar has been so high yeah we
all got together we talked about it
we're like maybe like an end credits
dance or something like we cannot let
the Ken's take this from us and they
just crushed it and especially because
there's so many movies that Greta is
referencing
um you know whether it's like Greece or
you know any of the 50 Sound Stage
musicals where there's like any time you
know you watch Like An American in Paris
and it's like oh he's trying to figure
something else okay Dreamscape ballet to
like Express his feelings it's kind of
that thing but it's so
brilliant it's so well done and the guys
crushed it I mean the choreography y'all
nailed it it was amazing it was
something else it was amazing it did
give me grease lightning Vibes actually
now that you mentioned right it says yes
100 when you think back you're like wow
Grease does that a lot like suddenly
they're like in like a Dreamscape sort
of like dance so I recently spoke with
Gal Gadot actually who of course was up
for Barbie you did okay we ran
it down to being a sequel actually she
said and I quote she would do anything
for you and then she loves you Margo I
love you I'll do anything with you I'll
be I'll do anything with you I love her
so much when I swear we were like
giggling and we're like oh my gosh and
she was like all I get asked about is
Barbie and I'm not even in Barbie and I
was like you're our Dream Bobby she was
she was always we always knew that she
was unavailable because she was doing
Snow White at the same time that we were
doing Barbie so we knew it wasn't
possible but she was our barometer for
Barbie energy whenever we'd be like
what's a Barbie like and we're like
because both Greta and I have had
experiences where we've met gal at
events before we've known and she like
within two minutes makes you feel like
she's like you're her best friend and
you feel so loved and valued and also
like she's so pretty and and like just
so nice and so we're always like
you know someone that you meet for two
seconds you're like
it's so nice and I love you yeah oh well
speaking of being nice and in love you
two will be working together again right
you're going from Barbie to an Ocean's
11 film together maybe hopefully
hopefully oh so I'm just saying you guys
aren't tired of each other yet I assume
I'm not are you sicking me yet
are you kidding me
look at me you see how hard I'm counting
it is getting so hard it is daylight
look what you've done I don't
[Music]